hey what's up guys I'm Kay PhD here so
basically ever since Android 4.1 has
been announced at Google i/o one of the
main features that people have been
looking at is Google voice search and
Google now and the comparative side on
iOS being serious so what better way to
compare the two than to do a
side-by-side head-to-head comparison a
battle of Siri versus Google Voice
Search let's get started so start off
easy with basic factual questions
questions about the weather questions
about you know data and information and
that we'll see has a pretty one-sided
bias and the results let's go ahead and
hook is it going to rain tomorrow how
hot is it in Topeka the high temperature
in Topeka Kansas will be 99 degrees
what's the weather in Belgium convert
one pound two ounces I found this for
you
what is the capital of Florida I found
this for you who is the president of
Egypt for you I found this for you
how big is Japan how long is the Golden
Gate Bridge this might answer your
question how tall is this Sears Tower
how tall is yamin would you like to
search the web for how tall is young on
a when is Tiger Woods's birthday ok here
you go
so there you go that's a look at the
easier side of the questions and now a
slightly more difficult set of questions
by the way you can see all the questions
I'm asking in the link in the
description take a look at this did the
Yankees win okay how about a web search
for did the Yankees win searching the
web for did the Yankees win
what movies has Brad Pitt been in 22 of
them are fairly close to you where are
nearby theaters I found three local
theaters fairly close to you where can I
get sushi nearby I found 17 sushi
restaurants 15 of them are fairly close
to you what is the area code for Beverly
Hills answer your question remind me to
go to the gym tomorrow at 9:00 a.m.
here's your reminder for tomorrow at
9:00 a.m. shall I create it okay I'll
remind you set a timer for two minutes
note to self pick up some more cereal
note to self okay I can take that note
for you
just tell me what you want it to say
pick up some more cereal noted so
overall what did we learn well Google
now and Google Voice Search tend to be
really really good with factual stuff
asking you birthdays whether very
straightforward information like
distances and sizes it's really really
good and fast at that that's thanks to
Google's algorithms Siri which is a lot
more conversational can tell you jokes
can have conversations with you can give
you advice Google search won't do that
but Siri also uses a lot of Wolfram
Alpha and its results you'll notice when
I was pulling up certain results that
had information in them you'd get a
whole cart of information Siri won't
read you off the Wolfram Alpha card but
anytime you see a car like that the
source is Wolfram Alpha and you get a
whole lot of information and that is
also something that happens to be used
by Samsung's s voice with Google now and
Google Voice Search you can actually see
the source that's being used with
everything that's being displayed in the
card so if you get a card for an answer
it'll give you a source and if it gives
you an image you'll also get the source
for that image and of course both of
these competitors if nothing else works
if you ask a question it can't answer it
just defaults to a Google web search so
that says a lot about Google so that's
basically it guys what do you think I
mean I personally think that Google
Voice Search is really impressive my
actually started using it for more
factual stuff I know that Siri was
considered a bit of a gimmick by a lot
of people at first because it was very
very gimmicky seeming I don't know how
to describe it but it had a lot of
features that people would never use but
the factual stuff is very helpful and as
a side note I was going to include
Samsung's s voice but it was incredibly
slow and not even worth trying and
including this comparison so there you
go thanks for watching if you want to
check out all the rest of the awesome
features of Android 4.1 jelly bean you
can click that annotation right there
and it'll take you there and without any
further ado I'm going to go ahead and
sign off here go ahead and leave your
thoughts in the comment section below
and they feel free to thumbs up this
video if you agree and subscribe
more thank you for watching and I'll
talk to you guys in the next video peace
you